and dear fellow Scholars this is two
minute papers with Dr Carol Jonah ifahir
today is a good day scientists at Nvidia
have done it now I hear you asking
doctor what are you talking about well
we like to say that Ray tracing is the
Holy Grail of computer Graphics research
and within Ray tracing wave Optical
light simulations perhaps are the Holy
Grail yes the Holy Grail within the Holy
Grail however achieving that is really
difficult you see Ray tracing means
writing a simulation program that takes
a rays of light and bounces them around
in the scene creating a beautiful
photorealistic image note that I use the
word rays of light however light is an
electromagnetic wave yes a wave not
array if we simulated it as a wave
instead it could create a convincing
image of incredibly beautiful
microscopic structures like light
diffraction off of the scales of a
Brazilian Rainbow Boa or a piece of
boronite ore or it could create an image
of beetle shells that have multiple
layers that bounce light around between
them these beautiful wave effect can
also be observed in the spool guards of
some bicycles and other parts as well
all beautiful shiny rainbowy things that
are unfortunately almost impossible to
simulate this previous technique from
just a year ago can at least start
rendering the refractive surface of a CD
disc but look this one should be a line
not a collection of dots so
unfortunately no wave optic simulations
for us until today yes scientists at
Nvidia introduced a new technique that
can simulate light both as a ray but as
a wave too and this gives rise to these
beautiful effects oh my goodness look at
that gorgeous scene
so good and yes finally when it comes to
CDs rainbowy lines are now lines we can
have our Beatles our bornite ore and
even the snake now hold on to your
papers fellow Scholars because here
comes the best part it can simulate all
of these phenomena up to 10 000 times
faster than previous techniques and note
that this is a handcrafted technique a
product of pure human Ingenuity wow as
we are slowly approaching super
intelligence I mean these AI things are
starting to be able to decode Hungarian
words yes this is a Hungarian word
really and yes the translation is also
correct but such a pure handcrafted
technique is chef's kiss love it and
here is something that also made me
extremely happy look at this this is a
new work on how to simulate the
appearance of glint's shiny little Doddy
things in a simulator this can take car
paint materials snow shiny presence and
create a Next Level video and up to five
times faster than the state of the art
and does that mean that oh yes yes it
does all this is happening in real time
pinch me I can't believe it all these
beautiful footage in real time you see
there is a ton of action happening in
light transport simulation research and
these incredible papers just keep coming
out one after another breakthrough after
breakthrough now if you allow me I would
also like to show you a really cool new
paper from my colleague Christian freuda
who was not happy with the way we
compare the results of different Ray
tracing programs you see these two
images work computed differently however
this render was cutting some corners but
where if we use the usual previous ways
of comparing images we get some
information but not that much however
look
this new technique tells us exactly
where those Corners were cut I was a
small part of this paper too and if you
wish to read it make sure to check it
out in the video description Bravo
Christian if you're looking for
inexpensive Cloud gpus for AI Lambda now
offers the best prices in the world for
GPU Cloud compute no commitment or
negotiation required just sign up and
launch an instance and hold on to your
papers because with the Lambda GPU Cloud
you can now get on demand h100 instances
for just 199 per hour yes 199 and they
are one of the first Cloud providers to
offer publicly available on-demand
h100xs did I mention they also offer
persistent storage so join researchers
at organizations like apple MIT and
Caltech in using Lambda Cloud instances
workstations or servers make sure to go
to lambdalabs.com papers to sign up for
one of their amazing GPU instances today
thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time